let the pear tree in they're stocking up
as covered rules are dropped
but rather than anticipate a rush of
drinkers on monday
they're wondering whether they'll have
the staff to serve them current time
that is probably our biggest risk
because we're getting a ping and then we
have a whole team have to isolate for 10
days
and it's just you know we don't have the
staff to open those businesses so you're
getting to this stage where
the business is reopening we're starting
to make some money um
and starting to you know address the
shortfalls and deficits we've got and
then you lose them for 10 whole days
and that's hitting really hard thousands
of businesses have been disrupted as
record numbers of people are forced to
self-isolate
following a ping from the nhs app
nissan is among them with production
affected as more than 10 percent
of the 6 000 staff at its sunderland
plant are isolating
they're among more than half a million
people forced to stay at home
by what business is calling a pandemic
we're risking seeing a very significant
rise in people
required to self isolated in a factory
setting of course you can't work from
home
this this directly affects the output as
cases saw
legal restrictions are about to be
removed but just because you can stand
at the bar
doesn't mean you'll be able to from
monday there we no need to check in with
the nhs
app or to wear a mask or to keep your
distance but new government guidelines
says all of these measures could and in
some cases
should still be used it may be less a
question in practice
of how many covered rules are removed
than how many remain
the prime minister denies his shifting
responsibility for disease control
onto business business is perfectly
capable of understanding
uh what we are doing uh we're moving
away from legal
compulsion but we're saying that of
course
the pandemic is not over and sadly
people have to remain cautious the
guidance raises questions for office
staff and their employers too as the
work from home instruction is dropped
hannah's manchester-based cloud
technology firm will still be cautious
from monday the mass will be optional
the hygiene stations will still be in
place
the we will be leaving a space between
the desk just to ensure that people are
not too close to each other
this is just to ensure that we don't
wipe the whole business out
supermarkets tesco and sainsbury will
still ask customers to mask up
as will waterstones monday may offer
just a taste of freedom
with cases soaring there may be little
to celebrate
paul kelso sky news in oxfordshire